wahrscheinlich kennt ihr das auch wenn
eine eigene Wohnung habt erst vor kurzem
sind wir hierher gezogen und mussten
direkt mal ein paar tausend Euro
ausgeben für Möbel ich meine so ein
Roller Esstisch kostet mal eben 900 €
ein Kleiderschrank 1200 €. das sind
übrigens nicht die Möbel die wir gekauft
haben sondern einmal ganz normal von
Ikea was ja eigentlich auch halbwegs
günstig sein sollte müsste man malen so
mir reicht's habe ich mir gedacht ich
mache das jetzt einfach selber habe ich
mir gedacht und schau dann ob wir das
erstens günstiger schaffen als das
Möbelhaus und zweitens genauso gut
hinbekommen am Ende des Videos werde ich
den selbst gebauten und den originalen
Stuhl nebeneinander stellen und meine
Freundin Sophie muss erraten welcher
davon da gekauft ist
dieses Video wird unterstützt von Intel
so als erstes suchen wir mal einen Stuhl
raus ja nachbauen können und zwar auf
der IKEA Seite wär eigentlich cooler
wenn man direkt im Möbelhaus wären aber
und dann ist einfach leichter hätte auch
jeder andere Marke sein können aber mit
dem Titel kriegt das Video dreimal so
viele Klicks deswegen Stuhl es soll auch
nicht zu leicht sein ja also das ist
halt glaube ich gar keine Challenge
Stuhl hier der Stefan der sie Nachbar
aus und den finde ich halt geil aber den
Kriegen eigentlich selber hin der sie
noch nice aus der gute Ingolf
44 Stühle habe ich mir jetzt
durchgeschaut UI finde das sind die
nicesten aber gibt's nicht auch einzeln
ja hier jawoll den machen wir oh Alter
kostet auch 70 €, was schon echt krass
18 € gekauft das heißt bei 70 € lohnt
sich auf jeden Fall den selber zu machen
da spart man nämlich richtig gut also
hoffentlich zumindest im schlimmsten
Fall wird natürlich noch teurer das Teil
selber zu bauen vielen Dank für deine
Bestellung sehr gut es dauert jetzt vier
Tage dann ist das Ding da da ist er
schon aber ich packe natürlich erst auf
wenn unsere fertig gebaut ist das geil
ist aber was ich gerade gefunden habe
ist das jetzt hier auf der Website
einfach eine fertige Blaupause gibt die
ziehe ich mir jetzt einmal in
Illustrator rein jetzt hole ich mir das
Messwerkzeug aus und jetzt dass diese 40
cm hier 209 Punkten entsprechen 209
entspricht 40 das heißt ich kann jetzt
einfach diese Länge hier messen die ist
17,5 Punkte lang und die 17,5 Punkte
entsprechen dann 3,3 cm jetzt weiß ich
dass mein Holz ungefähr 3 cm dick sein
muss
aber wie bei allen meinen Projekten
erzähle ich dir das meine
dreidimensionale Konstruktion und
übertrage einfach eins nach dem anderen
alle Maße hier raus so machen wir die
Vorlage rein so jetzt gehe ich hier hin
Rechtsklick kalibrieren Klick einmal den
Punkt und einmal den Punkt an tippe ein
dass das 53 cm sein macht Enter und dann
ist es auf Maß so wir zeigen euch das
nach wir haben vorhin schon gemessen wie
dick das ist wie dick 28 weiß gell und
schon haben wir das erste Bein hier gehe
jetzt mal hin und dupliziert das einfach
mal okay also die ersten beiden
Stuhlgang ist fertig und ja so weiter
[Musik]
dafür brauchen wir jetzt eine 2,8 cm
starke Holzplatte eine die 1,8 cm stark
ist und dann noch so eine dünne Leiste
für diese
rückenlehnenkreuzstrebe Dinger da
insgesamt knapp über 50 Euro und wenn
ich mich nicht täusche brauchen wir
sonst noch gar nichts mehr was dann
insgesamt 33% billiger werden als
gekauft also ab zum Baumarkt
[Musik]
heute ist sowas geiles
ist das leider noch wichtig geworden
weil die Kiefer die im Original
verwendet wurde gab es leider nicht aber
mit ein bisschen beide sind das am Ende
genauso aus ich brauche am Anfang
erstmal die dicke Platte hier und ich
fange jetzt mal an mit dem vorderen
Stuhlbein dafür habe ich mir jetzt hier
was ausgedruckt
und das sehe ich mir jetzt mehr drauf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt gibt es Bandsägen action
[Musik]
so und damit ist eigentlich das erste
Bein schon so gut ich fertig jetzt muss
ich natürlich noch geschliffen werden
[Musik]
so und schon ist eins der vorderen
Fußballer fertig ich habe jetzt gerade
schon mal an einem Teststück heraus
probiert was genau das richtige Setting
ist für diese Oberfräse das sind hier
quasi so eine schöne Rundung hat und das
mal jetzt hier auch drauf
[Musik]
und fertig ist das erste Stuhlbein das
richtig schön geworden
[Musik]
das mit der Oberfräse also diese ganzen
Rundungen hier zu machen hat echt gut
geklappt was jetzt nur schwierig wird
sind die Rundungen bei dieser Sitzfläche
weil die sind im Original nur so leicht
abgerundet und da war mir nicht wirklich
Werkzeug dafür muss ich hier ein
bisschen improvisieren weil hier jetzt
einfach diese leichte Abholung dran zu
machen sind überhaupt nicht gut aus wie
wäre es mit 5 mm ja schon besser wie
wäre es mit 9 mm dann ist es komplett
rund und das gefällt mir eigentlich auch
am besten so sieht es zwar nicht genauso
aus wie ein Original aber mindestens
genauso gut ich arbeite hier gerade
übrigens einem Intel Evo Laptop mit
einem intercall-prozessor der 12
Generation und das kann ich von überall
machen egal ob hier am Schreibtisch oder
drüben in der Werkstatt weil der Akku
selbst unter Strom intensiven
Bedingungen bis zu 13 Stunden lang hält
und sich in weniger als 30 Minuten auf
über 70% laden lässt aber wichtigsten
ist natürlich Leistung und da punktet
der Intel Core Prozessor der 12
Generation mit überragender
hybridleistung
soll heißen man kann Anwendungen im
Hintergrund laufen lassen und dann
leistungsintensiven taskw weiter
arbeiten und durch die intelligente
Zusammenarbeit von Intel Evo Laptops und
Programmen wie Teams Zoom und viel mehr
werden Auswirkungen auf die Akkulaufzeit
Reaktionsfähigkeit und Konnektivität
minimiert ich nutze ja gerade zum
Beispiel Fusion 360 Event gleichzeitig
im Hintergrund Photoshop läuft unten
Youtube Video auf Youtube
designtechnisch sind die Intel evoletox
auch gut durchdacht mit dem Lenovo Yoga
Slim 7 Pro dass ich hier habe kann man
zum Beispiel die Bildschirm hier einfach
um 180 Grad aufklappen was zum Beispiel
mega praktisch ist wenn man gerade an
der Werkbank steht und die Baupläne vor
sich haben will es gibt noch
verschiedene andere Intel Evo Laptops
Check dazu einfach mal den Link in der
Videobeschreibung aus da findet ihr alle
Modelle und ich mache jetzt die
improvisierten Rundungen an die
Sitzfläche hier dran
und los geht's
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt den Fräser noch ein
bisschen tiefer eingestellt und dadurch
komme ich dann doch ein bisschen näher
an das originale Ergebnis an
[Musik]
jetzt wo alle Teile fertig sind werden
sie noch mal geschliffen zwei Teile sind
noch nicht fertig und da wird jetzt noch
mal extrem kompliziert die Rückenlehne
ist nämlich gebogen und holzbiegen ist
gar nicht mal so leicht moin hier ist
Felix der Cutter von Thomas leider hat
Thomas an dieser Stelle vergessen den
VoiceOver aufzunehmen weshalb ich das
einfach mal für ihn nachhole damit er
sein wohlverdienten Urlaub genießen kann
also um das Holz später biegen zu können
haben wir ein XXL Topf mit kochendem
Wasser vorbereitet und kochen das Holz
darin jetzt einfach für eine Stunde pro
Zentimeter Holzdecke kein Witz man kocht
das Holz dafür einfach
was ist denn das was ich hier riecht es
ist leihen
das riecht es riecht aber gut
okay geil komplett geil
[Musik]
so es sieht jetzt noch nicht so weich
aus ich bin gespannt das muss halt so
hart gebogen werden jetzt gleich beim
denkst es ist echt Schau beide zu machen
weil du brauchst ja die doppelte Kraft
schnell okay schnell Hektik
ja stimmt deswegen macht es Sinn das
nicht so zu machen wie wir
mach mal was
[Musik]
krass
so das ist jetzt kalt das ist fertig
sobald es kalt ist finde ich krass
also geht schon gut zurück
aber ich glaube die Biegung reicht sogar
lustig aber jetzt noch mal übel
überwiegen müssen tatsächlich aber die
Bruchstelle dadurch dass das jetzt mal
ein bisschen zurückgefedert hat sieht
man auch gar nicht mehr so krass top
[Musik]
das passt schon
während dieses wilde Schraubzwingen
gespannt Zeug Vorrichtungsteile draußen
jetzt langsam mal abkühlen und
hoffentlich sich dann nicht wieder
zurück verbiegt werde ich jetzt schon
mal erste stuhlhälfte verleimen für das
Zeug erstmal grob hin dann markiere ich
mir gleich direkt mal wo ich den Dübel
reinmachen werde perfekt und dann wird
geübt
und wenn du willkommen
[Musik]
dreimal und viermal
das wird jetzt einmal fest gespannt auf
der Seite und dafür kann ich auch
richtig nice sehr coolen Löcher im Tisch
verwenden die wir ja letztens gebaut
haben hier spann ich einfach so fest und
jetzt habe ich eine Idee und zwar kann
ich ja so ein Ben Stock nehmen und das
dann als Hebel nehmen und dann damit
hier dagegen drücken ich glaube das ist
schlau geht bestimmt noch schlauer aber
komm so der Dübel steckt das Teil kommt
drauf und jetzt brauchen wir richtig
Druck und das mache ich aber mit meinem
Hebel
geile Spannvorrichtung
und rein damit
mein patentiertes Hebelsystem kommt auch
wieder zum Einsatz
[Musik]
so das Teil ist fest
ziemlich schnell damit das natürlich
noch stabiler wird fehlen jetzt noch
diese andere Streben hier ich lege hier
auf jeden Fall gerade dieses Holzstück
einfach unter den fertigen Stuhl der
gerade schon ausgehärtet ist zeichne mir
das an dann geht's ab unter die
Brotmaschine zack zack und die beiden
Enden sind abgekürzt und jetzt an das
Teil und hoffentlich ja idealerweise
kann ich jetzt einfach hochschieben
perfekt und idealerweise ändert das
jetzt hier bei ungefähr 5 cm 5 und 5
jetzt müssen wir noch fest bleiben
können wir jetzt wieder hier so ein Plus
rein Markierungen dann gebohrt
also dann kommt er hier rein
und hier ist der fertige Stuhl also noch
nicht ganz die erste fertige stuhlhälfte
nice so ich mache es einfach mal auf
so hier ist das Brett ist gebogen so
sieht das jetzt das Teil aus und das ja
ist nicht so ganz so gut geworden aber
wir wollen das Ding ja möglichst günstig
machen dann kann ich jetzt nicht einfach
tonnenweise neues Holz kaufen drum muss
ich schauen dass ich das noch irgendwie
[Musik]
von innen das sieht das Ganze jetzt
schon echt ziemlich gut aus und da
kriegt man es auch perfekt geschliffen
da mache ich mir gar keine Sorgen aber
von außen sieht es halt echt nicht so
schön aus weil ja alles gespielt ist
und ich glaube da müssen wir noch ein
bisschen Leimen Lust auf jetzt mal ein
Teil ja auch an und versuchen ein
bisschen Leim runterzukriegen ich meine
viel Schleifen werde ich eh müssen mache
jetzt einfach mal gut Leim drunter
geklebt und jetzt spreche ich das mal
fest
[Musik]
hier der Rest hat auf jeden Fall super
funktioniert und das hier sieht bis auf
die Verformung hier auch
vielversprechender aus
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt ist der Stuhl erstmal soweit
fertig und da will ich mich direkt
einmal drauf setzen um mal zu testen ob
das Studium überhaupt bequem ist und
mich auch aushält oder ob der gleich
zusammen kracht ja das ist ein Stuhl ist
glaube ich genauso bequem wie das
Original sobald sie gut richten nicht
auseinander top ein Problem ist
allerdings noch
der Stuhl kippelt deswegen schleife ich
jetzt einfach eins der Beine solange bis
es nicht mehr macht
[Musik]
jetzt ist es tatsächlich so weit ich
lege was unter und unterlegen heißt
immer irgendwas mit Farbe und die
bekommt der Stuhl jetzt nämlich weil das
ist aktueller Super Plus
oh das war ein bisschen viel ja und
schon habe ich halt eine dunkle Farbe
und halt besonders heiß komplett ohne
diese schöne Maßnahmen zu verlieren
[Musik]
der Stuhl ist echt mega nice geworden
der muss jetzt noch ungefähr fünf
Stunden trocknen trifft sich gut es ist
nämlich gerade 6 Uhr morgens und ich
muss eh noch ein bisschen schlafen
deswegen ja deswegen trocknet er jetzt
eben am nächsten Morgen wenn man das
denn so nennen kann hat Thomas den Stuhl
dann als letzten Schritt noch mit
klarwachs eingepinselt
und fertig ist der selbstgebaute Stuhl
Bauzeit ca 2 Tage
den Stuhl aus dem Möbelhaus
zusammenzubauen das ging dann doch etwas
schneller
[Musik]
zwei Stühle einer ist echt einer ist
nachgebaut welches welcher von hier aus
soll ich das sagen können also wenn das
von hier aus schon sagen kannst jetzt
peinlich aber wahrscheinlich kannst es
von hier aus schon sagen also ich habe
die Vermutung dass der linke selbst
gebaut ist weil das so mehr diesen
Rotstich hat das sieht mehr aus wie so
natürliches Holz das lackiert wurde und
das andere sieht irgendwie aus als wäre
das so kein echtes Holz also von hier
aus so und jetzt und ich kann euch das
heute aber so Plastik ja das sieht halt
für mich viel mehr Halt nach
selbstgemacht aus und selbst lackiert
und auch hier da ist nicht so ganz
bestimmt
hier mal unbedingt boah ich total
der ist echt viel größeres Bild was
meinst du wie viele gekostet hat 20 Euro
so ungefähr 75
mit Versand was meinst du wie viel das
gekostet hat der hier hat in der
Herstellung gekostet 53 Euro für die
holzkosten und ich würde noch mal so
zwei drei Euro drauf sprechen für Öl und
Schleifpapier also insgesamt 56 Euro
kann man sagen also günstiger ich würde
für den noch mehr zahlen als für den gut
gemacht vielen Dank an Intel fürs
unterstützen von diesem Video den Link
zu meinem Intel Evo Laptop mit dem ich
den stuhlkonstriert habe aber auch zu
vielen anderen interviewo Laptops findet
in der Videobeschreibung schaut auch bei
Sophie auf dem Kanal vorbei da kam in
letzter Zeit auch einige Videos mit mir
online ist auch verlinkt und ich bin
damit raus macht's